[Music]
meghan trainor and daryl tabara are
married we're the cutest it's unreal the
couple began dating in 2016 and the Spy
Kids star popped the question in
December 2017 had you ever seen Spy Kids
before meeting if I had the DVDs
superfan yeah and I met him once before
like two years before we went on a date
but I was just a little songwriter no
one knows us and I went up to him at a
party it was like are you spiking and he
was like yeah usually nice about it and
I never fangirled over celebrities and
and like made a fool of myself but to
him I was like I Love You Man you're so
good and then two years later I were in
love and I remember calling my whole
family I was like dude I'm at spike it
last night and they freaked out Megan's
been gushing about a relationship to
Edie ever since just like you never
think you could be even more in love but
if we keep topping it and we just get
surprised and we look at each other like
how do I love you more today than
yesterday and it's that movie emotional
stuff the moment that you knew you're in
love he's me it's pretty right away but
it was like I've never been treated so
nicely from a guy especially like he was
showed up to our second date with a rose
in his hand I was like oh you're a movie
awesome so that's when I was like gonna
watch and she spills all sorts of
wedding secrets do you guys have the
wedding bands picked out for the big day
I think I bought his yeah with him oh
yeah I've like picked him out with him
while we were getting mine we're like
let's just get it right I'll party are
you thinking about that I feel like
Chloe grace Moretz deserves to be yeah
we text her all the time like you did
this girl um I I don't know I wasn't
planning on that but my management
mother my managers mother really wants
to do that for me so it should be huge
it'll be great as a songwriter the
wedding is is coming up I'm dreaming
around Christmastime
because my favorite and it's my birthday
and I want to be cold you know so when I
start sweating and dancing too much I
can like are you gonna write your own
vows do you feel that pressure of course
that's what you do right
you got it I'm gonna do all the right
things I'm just like gonna be in my
backyard I know that you said that you
don't want to sing at the as a wedding
well Darryl sing I've asked him to I
think you'll surprise me at least like a
dance or something like pull on my mind
that day you know cuz I get to perform
for him all the time and I'm like it's
your turn I want you to go up there I
love that are you gonna cry it's gonna
be over I'm gonna bake gay [ __ ] down
because we're gonna cry every time I'm
definitely gonna get married soon have
you said yes to the dress
no I have it but I said yes so a lot of
Pinterest pictures what are you thinking
princess ass crazy and tied thinking
like definitely a cape I don't know why
I've never won a game ever but I'm
thinking like the big gown I don't know
[Music]